Starting a business can seem like a daunting task, unless you have a partner like Shopify. They have the tools you need to start and grow your business. From designing a website to marketing to selling and beyond, Shopify can help with everything you need. There's a reason millions of companies like Mattel, Heinz, and all birds continue to trust and use them. With Shopify on your side,
创办企业看似是一项艰巨的任务，除非你拥有 Shopify 这样的合作伙伴。他们拥有你创业和发展业务所需的所有工具。从网站设计、营销到销售及其他方方面面，Shopify 都能为你提供全方位支持。美泰 (Mattel)、亨氏 (Heinz) 和 Allbirds 等数百万家公司一直信任并使用他们，这是有原因的。有了 Shopify 助你一臂之力，
turn your big business idea into... Sign up for your $1 per month trial at Shopify.com slash special offer. Deciding how to discipline a child can be one of the hardest parts of being a parent. Even parents of generally well-behaved children can find themselves at a loss when trying to discipline a defiant toddler or a surly teenager. In this episode, psychologist Alan Kasden discusses the most effective techniques for getting the behavior parents want, techniques that are backed up by hundreds of research studies. Dr. Kasden also addresses the question of spanking. Does it work? He tells us what decades of research have shown about the consequences of corporal punishment.
将你的伟大商业构想变成……访问 Shopify.com 特别优惠页面，注册即可享受每月 1 美元的试用期。决定如何管教孩子往往是为人父母最艰难的部分之一。即使是面对通常很乖巧的孩子，父母在试图管教一个反叛的幼儿或乖戾的青少年时，也可能会感到束手无策。在本期节目中，心理学家阿兰·卡斯丹将探讨如何让孩子表现出父母期望的行为的最有效技巧，这些技巧得到了数百项研究的支持。卡斯丹博士还探讨了打屁股的问题。这管用吗？他向我们介绍了数十年的研究揭示的体罚后果。
I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Alan Kaston is Professor of Psychology and Child Psychiatry at Yale University and Director of the Yale Parenting Center. He was the 2008 President of the American Psychological Association. He has authored 49 books on topics related to parenting, child psychotherapy, and violence. Welcome, Dr. Kasten. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with aggression in children.
我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学对话》。阿兰·卡斯顿是耶鲁大学心理学和儿童精神病学教授，也是耶鲁大学育儿中心主任。他曾任 2008 年美国心理学会主席。他撰写了 49 本关于育儿、儿童心理治疗和暴力等主题的著作。欢迎您，卡斯顿博士。非常感谢邀请我来。让我们从儿童的攻击性开始谈起。
When does aggression in children become a serious problem that might warrant professional attention? Well, one can look at three criteria usually, and the first one of these is impairment. And impairment means that somehow the functioning in everyday situations is a problem. And this is true of all the psychiatric disorders for children, adolescents, and adults. In the child's case, functioning at school and in peer relations might start breaking down. And so that would be one criterion. Is the child impaired in daily functioning? The second one is unmanageability.
儿童的攻击性在什么时候会变成一个需要专业关注的严重问题？嗯，通常可以从三个标准来判断，第一个标准是功能受损。功能受损意味着日常情况下的运作在某种程度上出现了问题。对于儿童、青少年和成人的所有精神障碍来说，情况都是如此。以儿童为例，他们在学校和同伴关系中的运作可能会开始出现问题。所以这将是一个标准。儿童的日常功能是否受损？第二个标准是难以管理。
Parents and teachers do all sorts of things to manage a child, and usually these work pretty well. And if they don't work and now the child's not manageable, now some intervention, some professional help is likely to be needed. And the final criterion is related to harm or danger. And this refers to the fact that the child may be dangerous to himself or others. For example, among the children I see, sometimes a child will drop a baby sister or brother or slap them or be really cruel to animals in some unusual way.
父母和老师会采取各种各样的方法来管教孩子，通常这些方法都很奏效。如果这些方法不管用，现在孩子变得无法管理，那么此时很可能就需要某种干预或专业的帮助。最后一个标准与伤害或危险有关。这是指孩子可能对自己或他人造成危险。例如，在我接触过的儿童中，有时孩子会把婴儿弟弟或妹妹摔在地上、扇他们耳光，或者以某种不寻常的方式对动物非常残酷。
And here's a case in which there's danger involved, and that's definitely the moment to seek professional help. So let's imagine you're a parent of a child like you're describing possibly there's a mental health issue, a really challenging behavioral problem. I imagine it's not always easy to find the right treatments for their children once you get to that point where you're ready to find treatment. What can these parents do? Well, that's a wonderful question. For one thing in the United States, for children, adolescents, and adults,
这就是涉及危险的情况，这绝对是寻求专业帮助的时机。那么，让我们假设你是一个这样描述的孩子的父母，可能存在心理健康问题，或者是真正具有挑战性的行为问题。我想，一旦你到了准备寻找治疗方案的阶段，为孩子找到合适的治疗方法并不总是那么容易。这些父母能做些什么呢？这是一个很好的问题。首先在美国，对于儿童、青少年和成人而言，
about 70% of the people who need psychological services receive absolutely nothing. So it's very difficult for people to get services under any circumstances. And among the reasons is that many professionals are in urban areas, and they're in large cities, and not all the psychology problems,
大约 70% 需要心理服务的人完全没有得到任何服务。因此，人们在任何情况下想要获得服务都非常困难。原因之一是许多专业人员都在城市地区和大城市，并非所有的心理问题，
psychiatric problems occur in those situations. But going back to parents and children, It is very difficult to get care for children, in part because a couple of groups, children, and the elderly in particular, do not have as many services as are needed compared to the adult situations. So it's very hard to get services. And then what services are you getting? There are now approximately 320 evidence-based treatments. But most of the treatments used in practice have never been evaluated.
精神问题都发生在这些地方。但回到父母和孩子身上，为儿童获得护理非常困难，部分原因是某些群体，尤其是儿童和老年人，与成人情况相比，缺乏所需的服务。因此很难获得服务。然后，你到底能得到什么服务呢？目前大约有 320 种循证疗法。但实践中使用的绝大多数疗法从未被评估过。
So it's not clear what one is getting when one does receive treatment. So my usual issue is to ask parents to make sure they are informed and ask questions. Seek professional help. The state psychological associations usually have a referral source to help parents. And then when you find someone, ask them, what will be the goals of treatment if I bring my child here? What will be the ways you obtain those goals? Will you talk? Will you have the child?
因此，当人们接受治疗时，并不清楚自己到底得到了什么。所以我通常的建议是让父母确保自己掌握信息并提出问题。寻求专业帮助。各州的心理学协会通常有转诊资源来帮助父母。然后，当你找到合适的人选时，问他们：如果我把孩子带到这里来，治疗的目标是什么？你将通过什么方式来实现这些目标？你们会进行交谈吗？会让孩子参与吗？
Will I be involved? What is the evidence for these procedures that you'll be using? and what is the time frame that I might be able to see some change. And the general rule here is we need a much more informed public so that it's not just getting help. It's easy to get help that will make no difference. It's easy to get the wrong help. And it's not as easy to get help as is, let's say, in medicine or something like that.
我会参与吗？你将要使用的这些程序有什么证据支持？我大概在什么时间范围内能看到一些改变？这里的一般规则是，我们需要一个了解更多信息的公众，这样就不只是获得帮助那么简单。获得毫无作用的帮助很容易。获得错误的帮助也很容易。而且，不像医学或其他领域那样容易获得帮助。
And so we must have parents who are more informed. But the overall point is that there are these very effective treatments. We're having trouble connecting them with the parents who need them. Let's talk about discipline, just everyday discipline. You know, there continues to be a debate among psychological researchers and practitioners about whether spanking children is effective. You know, where do you stand on that question, you know, and why? Well, first of all, I think about this in a different way.
因此，我们必须让父母了解更多信息。但总体而言，关键在于存在这些非常有效的疗法。我们在将它们与需要的父母对接方面遇到了困难。让我们谈谈纪律，也就是日常纪律。你知道，心理学研究人员和从业人员之间关于打屁股是否有效一直存在争论。你知道，你对这个问题持什么立场，为什么？首先，我对这件事有不同的看法。
It is not so much where I stand, or it's not even my opinion, which I would not regard is very important. Our science has amazing evidence, and the evidence is not confused at all in a few places related to spanking. And it goes like this. Moderate to heavy spanking in a child has the child at great risk for academic dysfunction, physical health, and mental health problems. How serious is this? If it's enduring and there's stress on the child, we know now that violence in the home, including excessive punishment,
这与其说是我个人的立场，不如说甚至不是我的观点，我认为我的观点并不那么重要。我们的科学拥有惊人的证据，而且在与打屁股相关的少数几个地方，证据一点也不含糊。情况是这样的。对儿童进行中度到重度的体罚，会使儿童面临极大的学术功能障碍、身体健康和心理健康问题的风险。这有多严重？如果这种状况持续存在且孩子承受着压力，我们现在知道家庭暴力，包括过度惩罚，
can change the child's immune system in a permanent way. And when the child grows up, he or she is more likely to die of cancer, heart disease, and chronic respiratory disease as a result of early stress in the home. Second point to make is that punishment now we know a lot about corporal punishment or not does not develop behavior. It does not change behavior very well.
可以永久性地改变儿童的免疫系统。当孩子长大后，由于早年家庭生活带来的压力，他们更有可能死于癌症、心脏病和慢性呼吸道疾病。需要提出的第二点是，我们现在对体罚（无论有没有采取体罚）有了很多了解，它无法培养出行为。它并不能很好地改变行为。
The behavior returns. So spanking or hitting or shaking or shouting makes the child stop the behavior right now. And that traps the parents into behaving as if it were effective. But in fact, it doesn't change anything. And so we know now from our science, what is needed is to train the behaviors you want.
行为还会卷土重来。因此，打屁股、殴打、摇晃或大喊大叫会让孩子立刻停止这种行为。这使得父母陷入一种误区，表现得好像这种方法很有效。但事实上，它什么也没改变。因此，我们现在从科学中了解到，我们需要做的是训练你所期望的行为。
So if you want to get rid of behavior, you could do some mild punishment, maybe brief time out, but you wouldn't want to depend on punishment to change the behavior, model the behavior you want, reinforce the behavior you want with praise. When you see it occur in the community, point it out and say, look at that child doing that. These are things that change behavior. It's really well studied. A couple more points. Punishment has side effects, even when it's ineffective.
所以，如果你想改掉某种行为，你可以进行一些温和的惩罚，比如短暂的暂停（Time-out），但你不能指望依靠惩罚来改变行为，要树立你想要的行为什么样，用表扬来强化你想要的行w为。当你在社区中看到它发生时，指出来并说，看那个孩子在做那个。这些才是能改变行为的事情。这真的是经过充分研究的。还有几点。惩罚有副作用，即使在它无效的时候也是如此。
Punishment fosters aggression. It deteriorates relationships. It leads to emotional reactions. None of those things is related to changing behavior. You can hear a parent say, you should be upset. What is the research show? Being upset has nothing to do with changing behavior. And so one of the issues is the side effects of punishment.
惩罚会助长攻击性。它会破坏关系。它会导致情绪反应。这些事情都与改变行为无关。你会听到父母说，你应该感到难过。研究显示了什么？感到难过与改变行为毫无关系。因此，问题之一就是惩罚的副作用。
And the final thing, this one is personal, the one I find most compelling, there is no evidence at all that spanking is needed to change behavior and tremendous evidence that there are alternative procedures that psychology has developed to develop the behaviors you want. And so discipline doesn't usually mean change behavior. It means what am I going to do to punish my child? As psychologists, we're more concerned with how can we get the behaviors you want. And the role of punishment in that is very, very minor.
最后一点，这是个人观点，也是我觉得最具说服力的一点，没有任何证据表明改变行为需要打屁股，而有大量证据表明，心理学已经开发出替代程序来培养你想要的各种行为。因此，纪律通常并不意味着改变行为。它的意思是：我要怎么做来惩罚我的孩子？作为心理学家，我们更关心的是：我们如何才能获得你想要的那些行为？而惩罚在其中的作用非常非常小。
What are some other techniques that you recommended to parents, specifically of younger children, to get them to behave? I would use brief timeout or very brief periods in which a privilege is taken away. Okay. Can you explain what a time out is? Sure. So time out is a period of time in which the child is, remove from the situation usually in which reinforces are not available. It could be isolated, but it could be being ignored,
你向父母（特别是较小孩子的父母）推荐了哪些其他技巧来让他们的行为变乖？我会使用短暂的暂停（Time-out），或者剥夺特权的极短时间。好的。你能解释一下什么是“暂停”吗？当然。所以“暂停”是一段时间，在这段时间里，孩子被带离通常无法获得强化物的情境。这可能是隔离，也可能是被忽视，
and it might be a minute or two or three. And a privilege would be something like you cannot do this or that for one day. Now, the natural tension is, from a psychological science standpoint, very brief punishment is all that is needed to have the effect you're going to have. And so that's the science part.
时间可能是一分钟、两分钟或三分钟。而剥夺特权则类似于：你在一天之内不能做这样或那样的事情。现在，从心理学科学的角度来看，自然的张力是：为了达到预期的效果，只需要非常短暂的惩罚就足够了。所以这就是科学的部分。
But from a parent's part, there's another part of that we neglect, and that is the parent has an interest in justice. And so you can't tell a parent, I know your child has just destroyed the ninth generation heirloom of jewelry and necklaces from the old country and deserves a one-minute timeout. The parent will look at you and say,
但从父母的角度来看，还有另一个我们忽视的部分，那就是父母对公正有着诉求。所以你不能对一个父母说，我知道你的孩子刚刚砸碎了来自老家的第九代传世珠宝项链，他只配受罚暂停一分钟。父母会看着你并说：
Doctor, you can't be serious. And so parents have a different agenda. When it comes to changing behavior, brief privilege loss, brief timeouts are all that you need, and they won't work unless you're developing the positive opposite behavior. And so the key, whenever you want to get rid of behavior, we train parents all the time. The first thing is, what is it the behavior you want?
医生，你不是在开玩笑吧。因此，父母有着不同的议程。当谈到改变行为时，短暂剥夺特权、短暂暂停就是你所需要的全部，而且如果不培养相反的积极行为，它们就不会起作用。因此，每当你想要改掉某种行为时，我们一直在对父母进行培训。首要的事情是：你想要的具体行为是什么？
Let's develop that. And that works really well. What about discipline techniques for older children and teenagers? Well, for teenagers, it all begins with negotiating. So when things are calm and there's no particular crisis and no one's rolling eyes at the other person or giving obscene gestures, sit down with your team and say, these are the things I want to be especially mindful of and careful about it, and we should talk about these. One of them is I always want to know where you are.
让我们来培养它。这真的很管用。对于稍大一点的孩子和青少年的纪律技巧呢？嗯，对于青少年来说，一切都始于协商。因此，当气氛平静、没有特别的危机、没有人对翻白眼或做粗鲁的手势时，坐下来和你的青少年谈谈，说：这些是我特别想注意和小心的事情，我们应该谈谈这些。其中之一就是我总是想知道你在哪里。
And so when you don't let me know, what are we going to do about that? I'm going to have to do some punishment. Can we negotiate how to handle this? And so whenever you can, you want to sit down and chat with a teenager. Why? Because when you give choice, when you give discretion, when you give an opportunity, it's more likely that you'll come up with something to the child will actually do and cooperate with.
所以当你没有让我知道时，我们该怎么处理？我将不得不进行一些惩罚。我们能协商一下如何处理这件事吗？因此，只要有可能，你都应该坐下来与青少年聊天。为什么？因为当你给予选择、给予自主权、给予机会时，他们更有可能想出一些孩子真正愿意去做并配合的事情。
And that's from psychology research. So again, for our science, that's a plus. And again, we want things that are brief. So if you take a privilege away, you don't want to say, you've just lost the first year of college to your 17-year-old. That's excessive. You want it to say there's something you can't do for maybe a day. And one also has to be very careful.
这是心理学研究得出的结论。所以对我们的科学来说，这是一个加分项。同样，我们希望时间是短暂的。因此，如果你剥夺了一项特权，你不会想对一个 17 岁的孩子说：你刚刚失去了上大学的第一年资格。那是过分的。你希望说有些事情你可能一天不能做。而且人们还必须非常小心。
You don't want to take away something that might itself be adaptive. So, for example, time with peers is not negative. It's usually positive. And so you want to be very careful of what you're using as punishment. And then again, you want to model the behavior and reinforce. So, for example, this is a pet peeve of parents I see all the time. My teenager rolls her eyes, gives me obscene jester, is so disgusted with me, it tells me I'm selfish.
你不想剥夺那些本身可能具有适应性价值的东西。例如，与同龄人相处的时间并不是消极的。它通常是积极的。因此，你必须对你用作惩罚的东西非常小心。然后同样地，你想树立行为榜样并进行强化。例如，这是我经常看到的父母的一大痛点。我的青少年女儿翻白眼、对我做粗鲁的手势、对我很反感、告诉我我很自私。
And so I'm really hard. I scream in her, and I tell her she can't go out when I do that. That's going to lead to no effect at all. It's back that it'll actually make things worse. So what can you do? So we find times in which the teen isn't always rolling eyes. So at breakfast, they said, you know, I'm going there after school. So you stop, and you say, you know what, this is so good.
所以我真的很严厉。我对她大喊大叫，并告诉她我这样做时她不能出门。这根本不会产生任何效果。恰恰相反，这实际上会让事情变得更糟。那么你能做什么呢？所以我们会寻找青少年不总是翻白眼的时间。比如在早餐时，他们说，你知道，放学后我要去那里。所以你停下来，然后说，你知道吗，这太棒了。
I love talking to you when you talk like this. Thanks for doing that. And just leave it alone. Don't go on an ad, how come you can't be like this all the time? That's called caboosing, and it ruins the effect of praise. So what we tell the parent is catch the child, the adolescent, at those other times and increase those,
我喜欢你这样跟我说话。谢谢你这样做。然后就此打住。不要接着抱怨说：为什么你不能一直这样？这被称为“尾缀赘言”（caboosing），它会破坏表扬的效果。所以我们告诉父母的是：在其他时间抓住儿童、青少年表现好的时刻，并增加这些时刻，
and this other part drops out. And so don't get into a punishment and battle with your child. You can't talk to me like that, I'm your parent, is going to make the child talk to you more like that. So parents are doing a number of things normally that is called normal parenting, that make things worse. And we can often redirect them to make it so that doesn't happen. Let's switch topics a little bit.
而另一部分就会逐渐消失。所以不要和你的孩子陷入惩罚和争吵中。“你不能那样跟我说话，我是你家长”只会让孩子更经常地那样跟你说话。因此，父母通常在做一些被称为“正常育儿”的事情，这会让事情变得更糟。我们经常可以引导他们纠正，从而避免这种情况发生。让我们稍微转换一下话题。
School shootings have been covered widely in the news media, and in many cases, these shooters are quite young. How can psychology better equip schools to identify these students? I think psychology can do a massive amount, but let me begin by saying what people think the solution is. The solution seems to have been that legislative bodies and people advocating for more mental health services, And I don't think that's going to be an answer or actually even very helpful.
校园枪击案在新闻媒体上得到了广泛报道，在许多情况下，这些枪手非常年轻。心理学如何更好地装备学校来识别这些学生？我认为心理学可以发挥巨大作用，但首先让我说说人们认为解决方案是什么。解决方案似乎是立法机构和倡导更多心理健康服务的人士所推动的，而我不认为这将是一个答案，甚至不会有太大帮助。
And the reason I say that is because the system probably isn't working very well now, and to put more money into things that probably aren't working very well is not very wise. Where does psychology fit? Well, it's not about providing treatment. It's actually about early identification. And here psychology is on its home court. And the reason I say that this is about better screening and better assessment. We need to assess all children on a regular basis.
我之所以这么说，是因为这个系统现在可能运作得不是很好，将更多的资金投入到可能运作得不是很好的事情中并不明智。心理学切入点在哪里？嗯，这关乎的不是提供治疗。实际上，它关乎早期识别。在这里，心理学回到了自己的主场。我之所以这么说，是因为这关乎更好的筛查和更好的评估。我们需要定期评估所有儿童。
in school, in user-friendly ways, and there are user-friendly ways in psychology that are really good. So, for example, we want to ask at the end of every school month, let's say, how is this child doing in school? Teacher could fill this out. How is the child interacting with friends? Does a child engage in any activities or social competencies out of school, playing an instrument, being part of some sport? Is a child a bully or a bully victim, or what's worse, a bully victim, which is someone who does both of those, and their adjustment problem. are very serious. And has the child been isolated or ostracized? We know so much about ostracism. And ostracism has a couple of effects.
在学校里，以用户友好的方式进行，心理学中有非常好的用户友好方式。例如，我们想在每个学校月末询问，比方说，这个孩子在学校表现如何。老师可以填写这个表格。孩子与朋友的互动如何？孩子在校外是否参与任何活动或社交能力培养，比如弹乐器、参加某种运动？孩子是霸凌者还是霸凌受害者，或者更糟糕的是霸凌-受害者（既是霸凌者又是受害者），他们的问题很严重。这个孩子是否被孤立或排挤？我们对排挤（Ostracism）了解得太多了。排挤会产生一些影响。
One of them is eventually leading to aggression against the system and the people who ostracize you. And one interpretation of school shootings could be that these children have been ostracized and are doing what we know to be the standard response to extreme ostracism. So my view, what psychology could do, assessments that could take five or ten minutes of child could be done on a regular basis,
其中之一就是最终导致对体制以及排挤你的人的攻击。对校园枪击事件的一种解释可能是，这些孩子受到了排挤，并且在做出我们所知的对极端排挤的标准反应。所以我的看法是，心理学能做的是：只需花孩子五到十分钟就能完成的评估，并且可以定期进行，
and they would pick up these children better. And over time, we could make that measure better and better. Now, the context for this is not about school shootings. We know now from excellent studies in the United States that approximately 25 percent of the children, adolescents, and adults walking the street meet criteria for at least one psychiatric disorder. That's right now walking around the streets of this country. And so we want to stop and minimize school shootings, of course, but we want to help children as well. And if we had a better way of picking them up in their everyday system,
它们可以更好地识别出这些孩子。随着时间的推移，我们可以让这种测量变得越来越好。现在，这背后的背景并不是关于校园枪击事件。我们现在从美国优秀的研究所了解到，在大街上行走的儿童、青少年和成人中，大约有 25% 的人符合至少一种精神障碍的标准。这正是目前在这个国家的街道上走来走去的人群。因此，我们当然希望制止和尽量减少校园枪击事件，但我们也希望帮助儿童。如果我们有一种更好的方法在他们的日常系统中识别出他们，
we could do much more. Well, Dr. Kazan, thank you so much for joining us today. I appreciate it. Thank you for having me. For more information on effective child discipline techniques, visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychological, I'm Andre Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们可以做得更多。好的，卡赞博士，非常感谢您今天加入我们。我非常感激。谢谢您的邀请。有关有效儿童纪律技巧的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。这里是美国心理学会的《心理学对话》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。